hi it's Matthew Martin from details and
we just finished the Versace show here
in Milan and it was bold and pumped up
for me it was all about the beautiful
overcoats and the gorgeous suiting the
students read their double-breasted or
single-breasted and whether they were
patterned plaid or printed they each had
a really great proportion all of the
coats were super masculine whether they
were in fur or they were in just a
traditional cashmere or even in a great
like silky blue saw and there was one
that was quilted it was in that typical
Versace for rogue pattern that i thought
was excellent and you know wouldn't be a
Prasad show without some whimsy and i
love the Donatella made lace underwear
for guys why should girls have all the
fun you know the thing I love about the
versace collection always is that it's a
hyper masculine collection and it's for
guys who are bold and not what you know
afraid to take some risks however the
thing about this entire show is that
there were so many great pieces that you
know literally every guy I know and I
know a lot of different guys there's
something in there for everyone for more
videos from Milan please check out
details calm and also you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at details
match